What should teaching and research in the
humanities look like?
I'm going to Grad School for literature
and I don't want my work to serve the
ideological possession.
Well,
the thing is,
first of all is that it kind of have to
educate yourself.
When you go to graduate school,
you know you have your courses,
but I don't think that you learn more
than about 10% of what graduate school
can teach you by taking the courses you
have to read.
And the mistake that most people read is
make is that they only read what's been
published in the last five or six years
in their own narrow field and that's
increasingly a bad idea.
Um,
the libraries are full of classic books
and I would say take your field,
go back to the beginning of the field.
At least read the people who wrote the
classic works.
Bring yourself up to date and then
familiarize yourself with as much
history,
as much history of art,
as much history of literature and
literature as you can possibly manage.
You want to learn as much as you can
about everything.
I would also say you have to ally that
with a certain degree of specialization.
You have to pick one topic and really
become expert at it,
but it'll serve as a doorway to,
because everything's connected,
it'll serve as a doorway to what's
behind it.
So you focus on one thing and read as
much as you can on that.
That's your specific discipline.
Then outside of that,
read as widely as you possibly can
manage.
The other thing I would really
recommend,
and this is also true if you're going to
university,
is it isn't enough to read.
You also have to write and if you're
going to go to graduate school,
you should write every day.
It's a good idea for anyone who wants to
develop themselves intellectually,
but even half an hour a day,
you know,
that's 180 hours a year.
That's a lot of thinking because writing
is thinking and you should be writing
out your understanding of what you wrote
or what you read and the questions you
have about it and trying to formulate
what you regard as clear questions and
problems and also clear answers.
Uh,
both of those.
And that's how I would say you should
approach graduate school.
Have you thought about slowing down
there?
Were people worried about how hard
you're pushing yourself with the
countless commitments?
Yes.
Well,
I would say that those people worried
about that include,
ah,
I don't know if it's me,
but certainly my family,
they're worried about it,
but I'm putting competent people around
me increasingly to handle the scheduling
of the public events,
for example.
And I have good agents in a good
publisher and,
um,
I'm learning how to manage this.
I think I've,
I'm not really interested,
I suppose in slowing down,
although it has been a bit much in the
last year and a half.
I'm,
I do better in some ways when I'm
working flat out.
Uh,
if my health was good,
it's better than it was by a large
margin.
And maybe it's still getting better.
If my health was good,
this,
none of this would be an overwhelming
challenge.
But I'm trying to do everything I can to
put my health in order and many,
many things have been fixed.
So,
yeah,
I thought about slowing down,
but I've decided against it I guess is
really the final answer to that.
That's the other thing.
You know there are times in your life
where it's not time to slow down.
It's time to,
yeah,
become more efficient.
That's the thing.
You can become so efficient,
you know,
you end up doing things in five minutes
that would otherwise take you a week
might.
That might seem like an exaggeration,
but,
and I suppose it is to some degree,
but it's not that much of an
exaggeration.
So as you take on more responsibilities
and you determine that you're going to
become more efficient,
the responsibility pushes the
efficiency.
So
what do they say too?
There's time enough to sleep when you're
in the grave.
Many who respect your work feel your
tweets are often impulsive or even
expedient.
Very funny.
In certain interactions,
would you consider a change in the way
you tweet?
Well,
I've been considering that for a very
long time.
One of the things I did in the last
month,
which that I think was productive.
Twitter's a hard disc,
hard medium to manage because it rewards
impulsivity and uh,
I have somewhat of a temper and I
suspect that it's maybe I'm more
susceptible to being,
um,
to being tempted to respond in a
too forceful manner.
Maybe I'm more tempted by that than I
should be.
Um,
but Twitter is real useful.
I mean it does keep me updated with
regards to the ongoing,
let's say,
war that's raging at the bottom of our
culture and it does enable me to stay in
contact with people,
at least to some degree.
And it's a great way of communicating,
um,
small but at least in principle
important ideas and also to let people
know about what I'm doing on youtube and
with the tours and,
and all of that.
People seem to
respond positively to those of
notifications.
So what I did do in the last month was
to find people.
I tweeted out one day,
I asked people to send me the Twitter
handles of organizations or individuals
who were reporting on positive
developments in a credible and realistic
way.
Human progress.org seems to be doing
that really well.
I thought it would be good to tilt my
Twitter feed toward or my Twitter,
uh,
my actions towards things that are
positive and also true as much as
possible.
And so I've started doing that in the
last month.
Um,
I feel somewhat of an obligation to,
if I'm being discussed publicly by
journalists or,
or other professors and they
misrepresent me or misrepresent the
ideas that they're purporting to
discuss,
then I feel like I have a moral
obligation to,
I suppose one is to defend myself,
I suppose,
and certainly to object to the miss
utilization of ideas by my fellow
academics.
I don't know if that's a,
yeah,
I don't know if that's reasonable or
not.
It's not easy to figure out in a
situation like this,
how much you shut up,
how much you stay patient,
how much you push back,
how much you fight,
how,
how firmly you respond,
whether or not to use wet
mean.
The rule I tried to outline in,
uh,
in my book 12 rules for life.
There's a chapter called,
yeah,
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them.
And there's a philosophy of discipline
in there and,
and it really has two dimensions,
let's say,
or two.
It's,
it's at the juncture of two ideas.
One idea is that you don't want to make
any more rules that necessary because
you get tangled up in them.
So minimum necessary rule.
So that's a good guideline for setting
up any structure even in dealing with
yourself.
And then if you're going to have rules,
you have to enforce them because
otherwise they're not rules.
And so how do you enforce them with
minimal necessary force?
And some of that has to be played with,
you know,
and experimented with.
So you know,
what minimal force is.
Those are really good principles and I
try to govern myself by them in my
Twitter behavior,
but,
and I hope that that successful,
um,
you know,
sometimes when I've gone after people,
I went after a couple of journalists in
Canada last year who
wrote I would,
what I regard as scurrilous and
incompetent articles.
That's a bad combination.
You know,
it was kind of a harsh exchange I would
say,
but it isn't clear that it was the wrong
thing to do.
So
it's hard to know how much you have to
skirt the ragged edge of disaster if you
want to do things right.
So anyways,
I am changing the way I tweet because
I'm trying to make it the bulk of it
informative and positive.
I guess I should say something about
that too.
You know,
there's a lot of really good things
going on in the world.
So we have poverty,
absolute poverty between the year 2000
and 2012 which was three years ahead of
what the UN had hoped would happen.
You know,
and cynics say,
well you have the absolute poverty,
but the cutoff was kind of arbitrary.
It was a dollar 90 a day,
if I remember correctly,
which obviously is quite low.
Um,
so it's not a real transformation.
It's like it's a real transformation.
Some number had to be picked to
represent that absolute poverty.
And I don't suspect the UN erred on the
side of capitalist over optimism.
Perhaps they did,
but hundreds of thousands of people are
being connected to the power grid every
day.
Fresh water's available,
not to fewer and fewer people,
but to more and more people.
And that's happening extremely rapid,
rapidly.
No starvation in India and China is a
thing completely of the past.
You never hear about that.
And that's pretty much the case for the
rest of the world except now.
And then for political reasons.
So you know,
everybody's got a cell phone or an oil
on anybody who doesn't,
is going to have one in the next 10
years.
And that puts in people's hands,
uh,
a degree of communication and access
that would have been absolutely
incomprehensible even 15 years ago.
So
it seems to me that the reason too that
I changed,
it seemed to me that it was worthwhile
to change the way that I was using
Twitter because all these good things
are happening
and just concentrating on this
polarization process that seems to have
gripped us in the West seems
counterproductive given all those good
things that are going on in the
background.
Now that doesn't make what's going on in
the west with regards to political
polarization,
trivial,
but it does set it inside a much more
positive context.
So that's something to keep in mind.